we have a great place to discuss
politics with fellow viewers it is the
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash read it that's our EDD
i.t about 21,000 if you can imagine
21,000 of our viewers and listeners are
subscribed free to the david pakman show
sub reddit users sneaky get posted that
white supremacist David Duke has
endorsed Tucker Carlson as the vice
president
you know David Duke always endorses
someone and I hesitate to make too much
of it I know a lot in my audience wanted
me to talk about this and point out this
proves that he's a white supremacist I'm
pretty sure David Duke endorsed tulsi
gabbard
um that doesn't mean Tulsi is a white
supremacist David Duke always does this
and I think it's important not to I mean
you know Hitler breathe the oxygen right
that's the that that's where I go on
this and I wouldn't really make too much
of it obviously I agree that Tucker
Carlson has fed xenophobic and white
supremacist ideas on his program one of
his writers was recently fired for being
discovered to have been posting racist
things under a pseudonym on the Internet
I'm not denying anything about what we
know about Tucker Carlson I just don't
think we should pay too much attention
to David Duke endorsing this person or
death or that person in a lot of ways
it's just David Duke trying to get
himself attention user cremation Lily
posted a very interesting graph that
shows the correlation between
coronavirus cases and political leanings
and when you look at the data you very
clearly see that the places with the
most severe outbreaks now are
overwhelmingly what we would call red
states whereas it is blue states that
are doing better right now now this is
going by governor now this is a little
tricky because Massachusetts for example
has a Republican governor who is one of
the more moderate Republicans in the
country and we have one of the most
left-wing legislators in the country so
to put massive massachusetts by all
measures really is a blue state but in
any case this gives us an idea that you
had the early hotspot
when it came to coronavirus and those
were really related to places with early
infections mostly because of a lot of
direct flights to and from the prior hot
spots meaning China and places in Europe
we didn't really know what we were doing
at that point we're now five months in
and now what you're seeing is a divided
based on state policy and very clearly
the places that are doing better have a
certain set of policies at the state
level and the the graph certainly
confirms that and then lastly
stilo fourteen posted an important
question about Donald Trump's urgent
press conference earlier this week
asking has a president ever called an
urgent previously unannounced press
conference to baselessly attack
baselessly attack his political opponent
in a completely incoherent manner for an
hour straight and then only take three
questions one question coming from
right-wing propaganda network Oh a and
the answer is no you know I didn't I
didn't really have to wrack my brain
thinking no other president has done
that and we have a press briefing
scheduled for today which I expect to be
yet another just absolute gong show and
know what we're seeing is unprecedented
panic from Donald Trump I'm losing give
me a piece of paper with criticisms of
Biden let me go out there and read it
for an hour I'm losing let me replace my
campaign manager with only three and a
half months to go these are signs of
desperation and we've not seen a lot of
this before
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it this is free I'm selling
you nothing it's just a place to discuss
the news and politics of the day with
other David Pakman show viewers and
listeners if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through in just fifteen
minutes and you get all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time to do all the reading you
want to do or if you just want to sample
a book before you buy the entire thing I
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blink Asst blink east has books on
politics philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video